- Oh, yeah.
- I think that's a shake.
- Now they're doing the booty drums?
♫ Brazil.
(samba music)
- I know absolutely nothing about
the Brazilian butt workout.
- I know what a Brazilian wax is.
- Is it the same thing?
- I really hope it's not the same thing.
- I hear it's by the same
people that did Insanity.
I've done Insanity, and it sucks.
(samba music)
- I just hope I can sit after.
That's really the only concern I have.
- I just want my butt to look good.
I don't care about the pain.
(laughs)
- I have never worked
on my butt exclusively.
I'm ready. You ready?
- Let's do it.
- Yeah.
- Woo.
(yells)
(laughs)
- That really hurt.
(techno music)
- This looks so fun.
They're making this look so much more fun
then it's gonna be.
- That's how most workout
videos are supposed to work.
- Are we dancing?
We're not dancing.
Are we dancing?
- This that boom boom workout.
Boom boom means booty.
- Boom boom me.
(snickers)
- What is this?
- Oh, we're not dancing, are we?
- I can't do that.
I can't even do that normally.
What is this?
- Are we dancing?
- I could do that pose.
- [Instructor] We're gonna do a plie.
- Do a what?
- A plie?
Oh, is that like a ballet move?
(laughs)
- This is starting to hurt a little bit.
- Oh, it's already hurting for me.
- Really, they're all
smiling like ha ha ha ha ha.
- Yeah.
- This is great.
- Liars.
- I wanna see the people
there having a hard time
'cause this is a hard workout.
- I want them to be
struggling as much as I am.
- (bleep) this, (bleep) this.
(laughs)
- What is that? I'm
not even gonna do that,
what does that work?
- You don't wanna? What does that work?
- Actually, I like this arm move.
Makes me feel powerful.
I have the power.
- What're you throwing?
- Uh I'm throwing trash.
- Oh...
- Just bottles and cans. My
relationship and baggage issues.
(laughs)
All that stuff, gone. Right
out the (beep) window.
(laughs)
- Stop, in the name of love!
- Oh my abs are burning.
- Still throwing out
the relationship issues.
- I really want to go to
the club with this guy.
- Booty drums.
- Booty drums!
(laughs)
- What the hell is this?
- Also, I feel it, like,
the back area here.
- Yeah.
- Like the top of my butt.
- Gluteus medius.
- I feel it in my gluteus medius.
- Just worried this thing's gonna snap
and like flick me in the nut.
- Oooh.
- Squeeze that boom boom.
- I feel like I'm gonna snap the elastic
with my gluteus medius.
- If he was my trainer, like one on one,
I think he could do great things for me.
- Yeah!
- I just don't know if
I can work with video.
(music)
- I challenge anyone, to say this is easy.
- if you're looking for a butt workout,
this is probably a pretty good one.
If you're not, I don't
know why you'd do this.
- Yeah I don't know if I would consider
doing the whole program.
As a dude, I need to,
like you said before,
pump weights.
- I like to hit the weights.
- The 60 day workout is just crazy.
Definitely would never ever put myself
through something like that.
- I would actually be willing
to pay for this workout
but not because I care
about my butt that much
but because it offers cardio.
- I don't know if I mean to be doing this,
but I'm clenching my butt.
(laughs)
- Totally.
- After the workout. So it's
like, my butt is tighter.
- Butt stain, right
there. Outline of my butt.
It's pretty gross.
- Aw, I have one too. Aww.
(music)